yes place one behind you I can't wait to
start plating up the start now when we
dress the salad like a dress it lightly
ok 1 tablespoon our vinaigrette in there
good ok and lightly dress it don't go
crazy if you flood the salad it becomes
very soggy hands in and tossed and make
sure got a nice even distribution of the
nuts the salad yes ok excellent
clearly you've been practicing our
because christ almighty right
take a nice handful always go to the
first plate first and not just sort of
spill your place on the way over there
now over sell it in nice little Mound
ok and then from there okay all the way
and the most important thing now is
keeping a salad nice and crisp make sure
we got those really nice sort of walnuts
at the bottom
take your amazing croutons here we go a
little helicopter landing pad push the
crouton down okay and then these little
babies eat food and very carefully lift
them up because inside is slightly
liquid place that wonderful ghost cheese
on top of the salad and then get your
vinaigrette the most amazing vibrant
nice citrusy Apple vinaigrette and just
blaze around the plates with the
vinaigrette be quite generous with it
the combination of the Apple the goat
cheese walnuts okay
that looks fantastic and there you have
the most amazing horn goat cheese salad
with Apple vinaigrette
done